I got a question recently from when my
youtube viewers love you guys gyro cello
to ask what do you know about the music
business you have any advice for bands
who are trying to make it and don't know
how to market themselves so great
question thanks for writing in here's
what i would say for people who are
trying to start a band and trying to
make it successful okay three things the
first one is you gotta practice you got
to get better this is a really
competitive market you're getting into
okay people are really really really
good and not making a big wave or big
name for themselves you have to get
better you've got to treat this like a
business every day you need to be
practicing this isn't let's come over
Thursday night we'll have a jam session
in our garage okay I'm talking like if
you really want to build the bank you
have to be committed to this if this is
your passion you've got to own this and
every day take action and get better
because most bands right now you're just
not good enough yeah it's not that you
can't get there it's just right now your
quality is not good enough you've got to
practice to get better and this isn't
just forbearance is for for anybody
who's trying to develop a skill i look
at public speakers i look at even myself
and how I've grown a look at the videos
that I've done you look at my videos now
you can / than how I was before and this
is like a thousand videos later a
thousand videos that's crazy I put in
crazy amounts of time preparing for
these videos and making them the best
video i think i can make at the moment
you got to get better you need to
practice I've been watching a couple
videos on unwrapped history getting into
that a little bit and watching
interviews with little Wayne and he says
he tries not to sleep because he's just
so focused on getting his workout I
watched the west coast customs show
where they were doing Snoop Dogg's car
and he wanted to have a station a lab in
inside his car so even when he's
traveling he can work these guys are
workers they're constantly trying to get
better even though
they're at the top of their game they're
still working to practice and get better
that's got to be your mindset that has
to be your attitude so you have to
produce better stuff and your band has
to be on board if you're the only one
who's we've got to really get better
guys we got to practice and maybe
there's a problem here does everybody in
your band want this as badly because I
guarantee you you look at any of your
your favorite bands whatever genre
you're in look at the top bands and you
look up to the most there's a lot of
hard work and passion I went into making
those songs they work on their skills
every day to get better and that's what
you need to do that's that's the first
thing that's where a lot of people fall
down because if you have great marketing
it's not going to help you if you're not
really good and what you're doing second
thing expose yourself okay what I want
you to do is film yourself on a regular
basis let people know about you you're
in a very visual medium right you have
you have a band going you have songs
you're creating if you're just covering
other people are doing your own stuff
create a youtube channel and post do it
consistently I'm talking a couple of
times per week that's what I want you
creating and it's maybe it's maybe songs
that you've created maybe it's a jam
session clips from a jam session maybe
it's just a personal message from you or
somebody else in the band but regular
content going to your YouTube channel so
you can start getting exposure what I
want you to do is get a following get
people subscribing to you right if the
stuff that you're putting out as crap
because you haven't practiced enough
nobody's going to subscribe so it still
depends on you practicing and getting
better what you do but if you do that
you're producing regular great quality
footage and content for your channel
people will start to subscribe I look at
my channel here a lot of people
subscribe and then every time I launched
a new video people start watching it
right away because they subscribe to it
and so that's what you want to do you
want to start building an audience a fan
base so that you have some leverage and
power when you get to go to hopefully
get a major recording deal for yourself
and then the third thing and this is a
against a creative little marketing
technique I would try to cover popular
songs and make it your own style so I
don't know what
style you have but it doesn't really
matter you could take any song and make
it your style so you can take a popular
rihanna song or a popular jay-z song or
popular even an old-school particular
take a boys to men sound take a Beatles
song anything and even if it's totally
outs like if you are death metal band
take a boys to men song and make it your
own because people are searching for
those covers and you'll get discovered
on YouTube and they'll say yeah that's I
love those guy I love the sound I love
what they did with that song and they're
gonna want to watch all the other stuff
that you're doing and you're getting to
subscribe and you'll build momentum and
you'll get people contacting you saying
can you play it our gig can you sign
this deal you want to do some kind of
endorsement deal with us but you gotta
build up momentum so one practice
everyday practice get better you're not
good enough yet get better to record
everything a couple times per week a new
video coming to your channel if it's a
new song a cover behind the scenes a jam
session a message from the band
something keep your fans happy and
number three start doing covers of
popular songs and make them your own
style make them amazing so you can start
building some attraction that's my
advice or bands good luck believe for
those you're watching you liked the
video give it a thumbs up let me don't
you think leave a comment below you have
a question for me leave it in the
comments section I'm a good video
response just like this one and
subscribe to the channel if you want to
see more videos just like this thank you
so much and I'll see you see